i literally cannot believe it's
happening it took a little more than
just some asgardian magic
to make loki look as good as it did the
loki series was one of the mcu's most
visually stunning entries yet
from the impeccably well-designed
offices of the tva
to the vast reaches of the void or even
our beloved alligator loki
loki's special effects didn't disappoint
here's a look at some of the behind the
scenes magic of loki
why the hell is there an alligator in
here one of the biggest highlights of
the season
was of course the alligator variant of
loki
who took the internet by storm when he
was featured in episode 5
journey into mystery since the loki team
obviously couldn't get a real alligator
to play the reptilian variant director
kate herron
revealed on twitter that the crew
settled on this blue plush
googly-eyed alligator what a cutie tom
hiddleston
clearly convinced us in this scene as
the variant president loki's hand is
bitten by the scaly variant
especially since the one biting him was
actually just a plush blue doll
i mean who's to say he's even a loki
variant
he's green isn't he kate herron has
talked about how her love of monster
movies
greatly influenced how eliath was
integrated into episode 5.
heron cited several inspirations behind
the monster's digital creation
with obvious ones being nature thermal
lighting and volcanic
eruptions what is most surprising is
that heron was also inspired by the
classic film
jaws to wait and build up the full
reveal of goliath
lamentas city is prominently featured in
the third episode
appropriately titled lamentis you may be
surprised to learn
that a huge practical set for the alien
town was built entirely on a studio
backlot
the art directors of the show wanted to
make sure that the town had a more
frontier-like aesthetic but still have
its otherworldly feel
blacklight paint was used for several of
the buildings
and the final product actually looked a
bit different than it did on set
that's because during several scenes the
buildings themselves became
light sources for the night time setting
i have to say
the most amazing one of the most amazing
sets i have ever been on
the seemingly one take chase sequence
was actually eight or nine shots
stitched together
according to cinematographer autumn
derald arkapal
it took nearly a year's worth of prep
for this specific sequence
a dolly vehicle was even used to track
hiddleston
and sofia de martino as they made their
perilous trek throughout the city
the way that we film them we hide them
so that they feel
seamless so you feel like it's one shot
from start to finish
the cutesy miss minutes is
simultaneously a calming presence
but also one that is intimidating since
the team behind loki couldn't actually
create a hologram for miss minutes
a lamp with cardboard eyes on suitcase
wheels was used as her stand-in
the lamp was also used to create miss
minutes luminous orange glow that she
gives off
this scene from the beginning of episode
2 shows hiddleston in his cubicle
acting against miss minute's lamp
standin
watch it where's your manners the tva
and its architecture is one
of the most unique visual aesthetics in
the mcu
while a lot of the different rooms and
offices in the tva were physical sets
the organization's city-like landscape
that resides outside the windows
obviously required quite a bit of
digital work
as can be seen in this scene in episode
2 the variant
where loki uses mobius's lunch to
demonstrate the nexus events
blue screen was used to show off the
landscape that was inspired by the likes
of blade runner and terry gilliam's
brazil
while the main point of this scene is
the god of mischief's demonstration
the inclusion of the background shows
just how attentive to detail the team
was
as loki is stripped of his fine as
guardian leather by the tva's robot in
episode 1
glorious purpose we see him literally
fall into a dull office space
instead of using cgi and full green
screen the crew used an
actual trap door for hiddleston to drop
down into after forcibly donning his
bleak tva jumpsuit
according to tom hiddleston richard e
grant was the creative team's first
and only choice to play the older
variant of loki
in fact the concept art even depicted
grant as the aging variant
grant's bright yellow and green costume
is actually inspired by the costume that
loki wore in the early comics
grant had to act out his magical powers
that would be added later via visual
effects
there's only one person we thought of
and it was richard
and if we if you'd said no i don't know
what we would have done really
the citadel at the end of time featured
in the season finale
for all time always was designed to look
as if it was carved from the asteroid it
resides on
behind the scenes shots reveal that some
of the looming citadel was actually on
set
and not just cgi magic the wizard of oz
served as inspiration with the vastness
of the citadel representing the
loneliness of he who remains
this is wild
one of the biggest reveals in all of
season 1 was easily the appearance of he
who remains
who is in fact a variant of future mcu
big baddie kang the conqueror jonathan
magers had
actually joined the cast during the last
week of filming with heron assisting
with the casting
major's costume for he who remains is
made to look like it comes from various
different time periods
there's a victorian cape the shoes of
genghis khan
and the pants are from mongolia you know
you just mix and match it together
and it informs the character time travel
is a key component
in loki and one of the most prominent
places in time loki takes us to
is the doom city of pompeii in episode
2. we are from the future right
this sequence while not a lengthy scene
still required the series creative team
to build a small set
resembling the city from props costumes
and
even live goats renslayer and sylvie are
two of the biggest driving forces
throughout loki
in their fight scene at the end of
episode 4 the nexus event
was one of the most memorable fight
scenes in all of season 1.
gugu umbatura revealed the distinct
differences between the two characters
fighting styles
renslayer is much more of a tactical
force
a trained soldier and rule follower
meanwhile sylvie is more of a streetwise
character who likes to go off the books
even loki himself has a different kind
of fighting style which is much more
elegant and performed in a ballet-like
fashion
the stunt team worked hard to make sure
that the fight scene would make sense
for the overall story
and if it would fit the characters we've
come to know and love
oh wow this woman can fight ah
the time theater scene in episode 1
between loki and owen wilson's mobius
is one of the more emotional and
character driven moments
in season 1. as a newbie with the mcu
wilson didn't know much about the
character of loki which led hiddleston
to give him the background he needed to
know about the character
this was nicknamed the loki lectures by
hiddleston
wilson noted that these talks would
often work its way into the show's
dialogue
since marvel is privy to secrecy in all
of their productions
wilson and hiddleston didn't know what
they were watching in the sequence
with the director having to tell
hiddleston the setup so he could recall
the scenes from the past
films the waiting room set in episode 1
may have been a simple set but it was a
favorite among the cast and crew
the set was designed to look compact
tight and claustrophobic
the ceilings were only seven feet and
six inches from the ground
not giving hiddleston too much headspace
the circles on the ceiling
each had a light bulb with a chrome tip
almost like
eyeballs watching over loki is one of
our simplest sets
and yet it's a lot of people's favorite
ren slayer's office was another example
of a set that was mainly physical
but used cgi to display its exterior
the office was made to exemplify
rentslayer's staunch and authoritative
personality
the statues of the timekeepers were
actually on set
but the background from outside the
windows was created
entirely from cgi
loki is easily one of marvel studios
most unique productions
and its visual style is a large reason
why it's equally
story driven as well as providing
stunning visuals that call back to
classic sci-fi titles
the series definitely served its
glorious purpose
what was your favorite moment from loki